[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record
we're talking about what julia's back
hi everyone yay it's been forever
what's good your hair's been so
it's gotten so long dude for real like
sometimes i worry that when i take a
[ __ ] i might like scoop oh my god
wait from the back or from the eye
cause you know are a lot of girls who
are super into like having their hair
super long
i always think about that i'm like does
it ever
just accidentally brush you know when i
was little
and like i was really really little and
i had like longer hair and i'd be on the
toilet and i used to go like this
and so like i'd be like on the toilet
waiting whatever and then i'd go like
and i'm like oh my hair could touch my
butt just to tickle your [ __ ] a
little bit
i'd be like feeling like the hair brush
up against like the top of my
my butt yeah that's how i feel like when
i'm like taking your [ __ ] and then like
i feel somebody's like i'm like oh what
is that and i'm like
oh it's my hair and i was like oh you
gotta screw this down
don't scoop any poop on it we're just
like
okay we're good
i felt the tip of the painting brush
yeah we're just like oh yeah we're good
we're good
you're two inches of hair away from
being a weird horse chick by the way
a weird horse what does that mean weird
horse chicks always have that long
hair man yeah yeah the ones that like
act like they're they're they're a horse
no no no the ones that like horses
you don't need to be the horse they just
need to be on the horse
they just gallop around like do horse
chicks have
long hair oh wait oh yeah they always
have long hair yeah you got to get that
shot for the gram where it's [ __ ]
like flowing behind them as they're like
galloping they want to match the horse
that they're
yeah exactly they're equestrian i'm
sorry
i love pedestrians i mean horses are my
favorite animals oh they are
yeah you know that that matches the look
and everything right she's a horse
is it only now that wait did when you
cut your hair did it change
or you sniffed it you're just like you
know i kind of like turtle take it over
no it doesn't no no damn
how has your rona been how how's your
ronin been my brother's been good
um i've just been working at home so
it's kind of nice i save like
a lot of money from like not having to
spend gas and i'm just like chilling at
home and i'm saving money because i'm
just eating food at home so
yeah it's great it's great i also like
like my co-workers they're cool too
nice they're real fun do you get to
interact with them a lot since you work
at home though
uh yeah because i'm in a position where
i'm in like a lot of meetings with like
different people zoom meetings yeah well
not
all google meet but like professional
here in like pajama bottoms and [ __ ] oh
all the time
or is it just put you have a top and
then pajama bottom yeah what's your
attire
just whatever i'm wearing i was gonna
say like but like if i end up wearing a
shirt for five days straight like i wear
it for five days straight and no one
says anything i'm like
whatever they would bring it up hey
they're such a chill company i love them
huh
i said do you think they would bring it
up they're like hey julia um you're a
mess yeah
it's like can you stop being a mess i
can smell you through this website
have you showered i would i would i
would love that if they were to say that
like that would be great because i'm
like
cool now we're on a different level of
friendship
yeah so cool so you've worked there
since before the pandemic right so
i think just here just around the
pentagon yeah so like
i started like early february
oh yeah that's like it's like prime roan
roanoke time
yeah and i was like in the office for
like about a month and then they're like
hey we're gonna quarantine for two weeks
and we'll see you guys two weeks later
and then after like the two weeks are
like hey we don't even know how long
this panda was gonna last there you
seven months later we sold the building
we'll see what happens
i honestly feel like that's where
everything's going next that's right it
makes sense
like get rid of your overhead dude yeah
it is interesting like they're
like different companies that some of
them say they you know they love the
office that they want to keep it
but there's a lot of companies now that
are thinking about just getting rid of
their office
like completely like twitter said that
they were jack dorsey was like yeah
everyone can work from home as long as
they want like forever
or whatever yeah i think uh i think i
think the uh the company that
the ceo of like wework which is funny
because it's we work and it's like
everyone comes to like an office to work
but i think they're saying that for
their company a lot of them don't want
to work in the office
so they're just trying to get rid of
that what awful sales pitch do you think
you could be like yo these are
totally useless for us but you know you
guys i'm really our own people don't
want to use it
yeah yes man
do you have anything that you do to cope
during rona to cope
yeah i honestly like work has been
taking a lot of my intent
my attention to it so it's like it i
start from 10 and i end at seven
and then by the time i'm done at seven
like there's really not much to do so
i'm just like at home just like watching
youtube and i'm like okay night's over
i'm just gonna go sleep
now like it's like a very boring
schedule but like it's very chill
about it but i didn't realize how crazy
the uh like america has been like
especially with like the fires and stuff
until um you didn't step you didn't look
outside your window
you couldn't smell it from the inside of
your house yeah literally i will wake up
to a smell
well no i have my windows closed i mean
like i open it up at night but then i
close it before it gets like really hot
but i don't know maybe i don't really
smell it i just probably have really bad
smell
smell smellers i don't know and you have
a really bad smell too
i know i do see that like on the outside
it was like orangish for a while and it
was like really ashy
i saw that i just did it i just didn't
see the grand
scheme of like how america was looking
like until um our uh like some of the
artists that we have in in canada
were just like yo your area like looks
like mad max right now and i was like
we're at mad max level like what the
[ __ ] and i started like googling images
i was like
yo what the [ __ ] is going on with
america right now yeah
it looks crazy
i didn't even know that was possible
that looked like a hellscape like you
know when you go into like the upside
down or like some other like alternate
dimension i was like yo
this is what this [ __ ] looks like and i
was like yo are we in the apocalypse now
you know what's cool uh i talked to
somebody one of my friends who lives in
uh
canada well not cool because it sucks i
guess because their air quality is now
bad because of
our
also like the whole country like there's
there i saw this report saying that the
smoke from
here or like the west coast ended up in
new york it ends up in the east coast
now
it's like going to europe or something
yeah it's funny because it's in the east
coast now but it's still like
like it's just like tracism out there uh
which is like a marvel
to be honest but still like the
difference is pretty uh
pretty startling because i i downloaded
an app that tells you air quality
and it tells you like it tells you like
the number and also
it gives you like a recommendation and i
was so mad because i looked at the air
quality
my sister lives in rhode island and then
it gives you an advisory in it
and then hours hours says uh warning
air quality is bad close your windows to
avoid the bad air outside
and then hers says open up the windows
and enjoy the fresh air from outside
i'm like what is this you [ __ ]
i got one of those me and nicky got that
too and then i got an ad like like not
even five minutes later for like hey we
now have outdoor seating at your
favorite places i'm like
uh yeah i know yeah remember when they
were all like
yeah you know quarantined but you can
still you know exercise outside you know
get some fresh air and stuff
20 20 was like now we haven't done that
yeah you can't even go outside
yeah cause like on on our air quality
thing it goes from like
green to yellow to orange to red to
purple purple to brown yeah our [ __ ] was
in
purple brown for like a few days and i'm
like oh my god like it made me scared to
even breathe the air
because it says like don't even go
outside without a mask like that's how
[ __ ] up it was dude i was so pissed
hearing the news that like the
san bernardino fire was started by a
gender reveal party and i was like
what is [ __ ] wrong with the cake
or a simple popper why do you need
[ __ ] private texas oh my god
it got me so [ __ ] mad about that [ __ ]
dude what happened before too
yeah yeah yeah in arizona i don't know i
was just
yeah cake's great guys cake is great
everybody loves cake okay
so the girl who first started the gender
reveal back in 2008
with a cake started
she's like the inventor of gender
reveals
she's a blogger i think she's in
pasadena right yes she is
so um she was writing because of this
one
like stop [ __ ] doing this like no one
gives a [ __ ] about your baby's penis
this much for you
like what the [ __ ] is why is that to be
a penis what kind of hair you want to be
vagina because they were having a boy
that's why
oh okay fair enough an explosion of like
blue
powder and it ended up starting a fire
that a firefighter has died now because
yeah
yeah i i heard that uh the person who
started gender reveal parties
um their kid ended up being transgender
oh really yeah that's what i heard
that's what i heard i haven't actually
looked into her that much
yeah fact check fact check if you gave
these same people the task though of
okay just stick to cake you know they
would light the cake up with candles and
start a fire
i think we should stay we should maybe
stick to ice or something yeah
ice cream ice cream yeah just ice cream
cakes or just like at home
do it at home don't do it at like a park
or in a [ __ ] forest
there you go not even don't even do it
in brush fire season it's fresh foreign
degrees when he did this yeah
ignoring the fact that everything's
flammable why do you even want to be
outside yeah
like it's it was so hot that day why
would you invite your friends to that
you asked him
hey come stand with us in 110 degree
weather no
no that's insane you guys do you guys
think the
gender reveal stuff's gone too far
because like i recently read
uh an article about a couple that rented
out
uh the entire building in dubai
a hundred grand a hundred grand to rent
out the entire building
just to have it light up to tell them
what gender their baby is
i i well me personally i'm not into the
gender reveal party because it's like
okay so i think if it's something that's
being revealed to you you have to
want one thing over the other it was
just a win-win situation yeah what are
you celebrating i think people just need
an excuse to do you know what i mean
i think people just need an excuse to
drink the whole gender reveal thing
once it started becoming a thing because
isaac was born in 2008
to the same year that she did her cake
thing right so it was totally not a
thing that i knew of until years later
but then once i found out about it i'm
like oh this is cute this is like a cute
celebration like
people have engagement parties yeah like
people can have gender reveal parties
whatever for sure but
um i think when they start
inconveniencing other people then that's
just [ __ ] up
or killing people you already have a
baby shower is what i'm saying
right like like you're like the
celebration of that the baby is coming
yeah and then now the celebration is
like it's gonna be
a gender you just roll the whole thing
together you should just roll it all
together in the same thing
that way they can figure it out i'll do
now right i mean that's what barton gio
did for their baby shower they did a
gender reveal there
yeah that makes sense and that's a baby
shower yeah and you get to figure out if
all the gifts that you bought for it or
like relevant or if we need to do some
returns or whatever we actually
do returns like at the place that if you
bought something for a girl they'll do a
free exchange oh that's nice
the boy option nice nobody doesn't want
more holidays though i gotta say
yeah so having little special little
things but gender reveal is so boring
like like that's funny i'm trying to
spice it up with an explosion
put [ __ ] money on it or something
that's
funny then i'm like okay and maybe
donate the money to the
well no i want to keep the money if i
win yes you should yeah
keep it donate the money to your baby
there you go oh
oh no gifts just wager just everybody
gamble on my kid yeah gamble i'm a kid
and then whatever is in the pot
you know he loses what though he goes
who's the loser here
and then brown the money we find out
grandma's been leaking info
waiting the bet and [ __ ] clean it up
break her knees
that's true yeah whoever would be
setting up the gender thing right
a little dangerous there yeah i don't
know i feel like
if we ever do get pregnant i would want
to make a little something about the
gender but not
create a whole party i don't want to
bring people for this event like that to
me
my own opinion is just like no we're
going big baby we're going to
have a destination gender review party
like our win
yeah that's [ __ ] up imagine forcing
people to fly out but not forcing but
making people fly could you even fly as
the mother
bearing the child i don't think you only
can't in like the last like the last
month yeah when it's like
later i'm surprised nobody has tried to
get enough
[ __ ] chalk or powder together or
something and throw it into a hurricane
so the whole hurricane's blue or some
[ __ ]
yeah it would be a cool idea right and
like category five it's really taken out
a lot of places oh it's blue like
oh the congratulations guys wow that's
pretty sick though
it's fantastic not exactly making things
worse well no actually
no you have to be close enough to watch
it be like
that and like everything it hits now all
of a sudden you're blinded by the blue
like all cars nearby their their
windshields are just yeah do you imagine
coming back to your like
ruined [ __ ] neighborhood just being
like everything it was a [ __ ] boy
[Laughter]
every house is blue
that's super funny do you have a do you
have a coping mechanism for handling
arona
me yeah his bit well it was animal
crossing for a minute
um but now it is
existing is how oh [ __ ]
that sounds like a very uh realistic
responsible way of coping with you just
just dealing within living life
yeah i guess i don't know i don't really
we were drinking for a little bit in the
beginning where things were really scary
and i think just to like take the edge
off a little bit it was like oh [ __ ]
we're
we started drinking but then we realized
like oh wait this is starting to be an
unhealthy habit so then we cut that i
feel that i remember there was a point
where i was like man i think we've
had a drink every day for like two three
weeks now we should
we should take a break and then so we
took a break for a few days and then we
had a drink again
it just got more fun again yeah i need
to re-up that uh tolerance there
yeah how about you steve oh yeah i mean
honestly i was
writing and that was great and all but i
was like i just need something else
because i have to
i need to talk to people and [ __ ] and so
bugging my wife
bugging our new kitties and then yeah
having a drink every now and then
i saw you guys are you guys are they are
you guys fostering kitties
yeah we are we're fostering four little
kittens and a mama kitten
mama kitty i mean in addition to the
other two cats that you already have
yeah whoa that's a lot
of our place smells like [ __ ] i bet
brutal are you attached to any one of
them i'm trying not to be
so i'm trying to be like how my dad was
to me in my childhood
[Laughter]
sounds like you're losing that fight so
far i am dude
every day gets a little longer it's
brutal man because they're so goddamn
cute yeah i think he finds you in like
how many days have you been in this room
that's why it smells like [ __ ] it's
thieves
legit the first night i fell asleep in
that room with the mama cause
so you lost it the first night no
well i was worried i was worried because
we have a double door right and it has
like one of those little things at the
bottom
oh yeah but the latch wasn't working i
couldn't get it to move so
if my other cats pushed on the door it
would open and i didn't know what the
[ __ ] they would do
because one of them is like a wild
animal our cat joe he's a yellow cat
he's
he got picked up from the desert so he's
a [ __ ] wild animal and so
he's a very sweet guy but i just don't
know what he'll do around a little
kitten
so i just stayed in the room just in
case so then how did you fix that
problem
i was able to use a tool and hammer it
down and i got it
nice you feel extra manly oh [ __ ] yeah
dude anytime like where's my tools babe
she's like
you're holding them you just want me to
see you holding tools and i'm like yeah
i do
that's how i feel too with my tools i'm
like i feel like a man are you using the
plural form even though it was like one
it was one tool
yeah i feel like i feel like there's
there are two times when your eyes light
up
one is when you're around casey and then
two is when you're when you're actually
holding your drill bit you're like
guys i got my drill bit this is so new
and you're just like playing with it
like
take a look at this yeah this sounds
nice at home too
it's impossible to use a drill without
going at least a few times
as you're walking around like when
you're about to do it still works
that's true you love fixing things so
much i feel like a lot of times you
you purposely have to step back and like
casey go do it or else i'm gonna take
over and
yes and and it's just like you gotta
like hold yourself back from doing
everything i need to let you have that
feeling too of like
holding tools it's just such a fun
feeling that i feel like i'm
i'm like i can tell you enough i don't
get any enjoyment out of fixing things
well i get enjoyment seeing you fix
things so there we go it's a selfish
reason i get i get very flustered with
fixing things
you can fix [ __ ] [ __ ] anything huh
yeah do you try
i try to pretty much can yeah you can
weld i don't know anymore
yeah i mean i think i've always tried
fixing things especially even when i was
a little kid
when i said tried because i broke a lot
of things as a little kid
like that looks kind of like fixable and
then i'd make it worse nice you know but
i think i've come a long way since then
how you learn
yeah yeah yeah best thing to learn on
when it's already broken you're just
like what am i gonna do break it more
like i remember being a kid watching a
documentary about
steve wozniak and jobs and how they had
a computer company their garage and how
they would take apart machines and all
this [ __ ] and so
and so i was like okay so to be
successful i'll start taking apart
machines when i get home yeah and so i
took apart
our apple ii or whatever and then i got
bored and just left it
oh no my parents handled it i don't know
yeah like was it the family's computer
that was like in use
it was an older one so i knew i was okay
i wouldn't get killed by my old man
but yeah it was one of those things
where i was like this isn't for me
you just left it in pieces yeah oh yeah
i can't fix that is it still in pieces
now
i'm sure nikki could get it together
yeah okay so you never
got into like building your own pc or
anything i do i can do that i built a
bitcoin miner
oh you did it it has
five graphics cards all in the same
motherboard it's pretty sick
but that thing will melt your face off
if you start it up without having good
ventilation i was gonna say where do you
use it still or
not yeah it sounds a little loud did
that too it humps
yes you know when it's on and so my
neighbors
because the whole power
dude the whole yeah it could heat a room
up no problem
but that's the problem is right now it's
110 degrees so that's good for the
winter then
yeah have you guys been experiencing
blackouts yeah like here and there
uh not at home but we were on a shoot uh
a couple weeks ago
and then when we were there i think it
was like it was one of those 110 degree
days
and then the we had a blackout for an
hour so we were shooting this building
that we only had the ac turned on like
an hour previous so the building wasn't
cold right it was just like
whatever cold air that was coming
through was that ac yeah
and the the power went out for an hour
so me and pat were just like
sweating furiously and we're like let's
just try and finish this then we can go
home
were you shooting people no oh okay i
was just like man you just got to
constantly like
keep it together or go to your car and
cool up for a little bit and then
yeah yeah no we're just like we just
gotta finish doesn't get out of here
yeah it was borderline dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
you